so who's my guest this week marina
lipvinenko
as ukraine is scarred by war my guest
knows all about the brutality of
vladimir putin and the russian state her
husband was alexander lipvinenko a
former kgb agent and source of british
intelligence
he sought asylum in the uk for him and
his family after criticizing putin
in 2006 he was poisoned with
polonium-210 in london and died as a
result
just last year a european court found
that it was kremlin operatives who were
responsible
since his death marina has fought for
justice compensation from russia and
campaigned to highlight the danger putin
poses to the west
[Music]
as russia faces isolation after its
invasion of ukraine what can my guest
tell us about how politics becomes
personal
here's a bit of what's coming up
my husband alexander litvinenka worried
people in 2006 saying
in a time when we all try to find
virtual being london in the same time we
have
another man who is going to be as a
hitler to put the blood all around if
you don't stop putting
we will have a nuclear war this million
people will die
marina thank you so much for joining us
and talking to me today i wanted to
start by asking when the russian
invasion of ukraine began
where were you when you heard about it
you will not believe but i was in
ukraine
it happened exactly when i was staying
in a very small city in the very west of
ukraine and during the night
it started and i received this news
it was really shocked
and what did you do
first of all
we tried to find all communication to
people who
were in kiev in odessa in haikov because
you know it was the heaviest
bombing and attacking these places my
very good friend she is a member of
ukrainian
parliament radha
she called me and think we will fight we
will fight to the end
and another thing she said i've never
took any ruffle or any their pawn to my
hands because i'm pacifist
but now she said i'm i'm going to do
this well this is all of the members of
parliament have been given guns the men
the women and many civilians for the
first time are going to be learning and
have been learning how to how to use
guns and rifles absolutely and i just
ask you please tell me what i have to do
how i can help just say talk talk to
people explain to anybody who can't
understand what happened between russia
and ukraine and send this message we
will find
fight to the end
and we're going to die for our country
the emotional feeling that you had
though when you heard that this had
happened it was beginning what was that
like for you because you have such a
connection to this story personally with
trying to get the world
to listen to you about russia
this was again a
sadness of being every time behind or
something happened
when we did talk about sanctions against
russia
during this moment when my husband was
poisoned this was all delayed or denied
or just tried to comfort people and
saying oh maybe we should not do this we
need to keep this relationship with
russia
then this was another event in georgia
but it was quite far away from uk but
then we have a skripal it was a
salisbury this was attempted to poison
using a chemical now you talk about the
poisonings in salisbury in england as
well as well and i was really
shocked i tried to prevent this might
happen again by doing all of this for
justice for my husband to make this
obvious
russia state is a quite dangerous state
and you need to understand it
and now we have this in ukraine and i
know
since 2014
it was asking for more attention what is
happening in ukraine and between ukraine
and russia what do you think drives
putin
you know when you're talking about putin
i would like to remind
what was his the greatest uh catastrophe
of the century is the collapsing of
soviet union
was he alone
not he's approaching only his 70s
how many people has him been educated in
kgb school bill being in the same age or
maybe uh younger did they accept this
change in russia no
they hate all this private business
they hate oligarchs in the same way
how like other russian ordinary people
hated them even they benefited from
putin's regime and now is this revenge
of these people from kgb who are still
alive still be very strong and they want
to get back russia to this
close position to be a soviet union they
don't care about private business they
don't care about uh people they won't
take total control
and only things when this russia became
completely isolated it might be stopped
does that mean that if
putin is stopped because he is the
leader
do you have faith that russia could be
different
do you have faith that or do you think
there are too many people like him who
are close to power and it would just be
another putin put in
of course i do have it because i'm
optimist and i always wanted to see
russia in a different way and i'm still
be proud to be russian and it's so many
russian people want to see russia
different
but
i'm so afraid before russia became bad
it would be something worse it might be
all under control of military
maybe they just decide to stop this war
because they don't want to die
putin being in a bunker or somewhere
else we don't know but he believes
everything what has happened during this
war
it's not so bad but military people
they're in real
situation and they see they just lost a
lot and people dying and they might
change some tactics and they might take
over putin
but they will take over and country as
well some people say putin is mad some
people describe him as evil
i recognize you want to talk
more broadly but what are your feelings
because there's very few people in your
position
where
they could say the russian state killed
my husband
uh which the european court ruled on
your case there's even fewer that they
can say it was probably putin who was
behind it
which the uk inquiry ruled
what do you think should happen to putin
and how do you feel towards him
of course i'm a not psychologist but i
think putin never been a person prepared
to be a leader
of huge country as russia
and if you
look to his past he never been ambitious
you know any political leader have
ambitions to be leader or being in a
party
or uh became uh a businessman ahead of
any business but never
and um i think it was real conversation
when boris berisovsky was alive it was
back to russia and this was a challenge
uh yeltsin is old and it's definitely
need to be somebody after him and boris
berzowski asked vladimir putin would you
like to be a president of russia
wouldn't say no
no at least i want to be a head of
casper
and this was is his
the biggest target he
wanted to be
and it looked like he builded all russia
as a big gas problem to receive money
from selling gas and oil
and of course you became crazy when you
should take some responsibility
when you need to
answer for what happened in your own
country and we remember every time
when it was some
terrorist attack or what happened in
this land it took a time when putin
responded
because i know he was just frightening
to say anything
he was not a leader and now when you
have this so much pressure of course you
might become crazier who knows
would you support the calls for his
assassination
if you call him bin laden
like bin laden if you don't have no any
others way to change situation
maybe but
i would like to say
my husband alexander litvinyanka worried
people in 2006 saying
in a time when we all try to find
virtual being london in the same time we
have another man who is going to be as a
hitler to put the blood all around if
you don't stop putin
we will have a nuclear war this million
people will die
this was the warning then yes in 2006
what do you think he would make of
what's happening today
you know it's so difficult every time to
say just like like that
but
um
only six would i'm very glad i can
see what sasha tried to prevent what he
tried to do i just said you refer to him
as sasha just so our viewers understand
and
every time what sasha my husband
alexander litvinienko tried to prevent
try to send message unfortunately he was
not heard
but now his words
his messages they're still very much
alive do you see that as as part of your
work to continue
i even can't call this as a work
it's my duty even i don't want a mission
because you know i still have
relationship with my husband you know
because i loved him and i think it's
just like
minimum of what i can do for him but you
keep his voice alive you do see it as
your duty to do
i keep his voice alive and he asked me
for this
you had to fight so hard for there to
even be a public inquiry into the
killing of your husband
do you feel
that if leaders had taken you more
seriously then that we wouldn't be where
we are now
because you can trace a line through
certain events
unfortunately yes and everything we now
calculated what we didn't do and now
maybe
yes we regret about but now i think it
should be more concentrating what we
have to do now
and not to regret anymore no i suppose
it it's just
i think some of the things that have
happened and of course with the killing
of your husband the poisoning of your
husband you know it's important to say
what happened there
people almost maybe weren't taking the
notice that they could have done i mean
regular people as well as leaders that
it's an extraordinary
thing that happened on uk soil and there
are other examples around the world
yes and even more i would like to add
this was not of course murdering of my
husband it's the worst what i could
received but this was using radioactive
polonium to 10
and this might make some people more
serious and concerned about this
when it was particularly proof
russia state used radioactive material
in the british soil
and this huge amount what could kill
many people
and we just lucky it was not many people
died during this attack very lucky and
of course since 2006 it should be more
serious uh for what happened but then it
was not so much support from the
european community it was not so much
support from america because it looked
like a
ordinary case
[Music]
and yes it wasn't
how was it to fight
try and fight for him
for justice
you are at the end of all court cases i
believe now
but what was that process like uh you
know you never know how long it could
take and in this case you just try to do
what you
capable to do i've never
have this practice to be in the british
court
and of course some people said after
doing something if you knew from
beginning you never done it
no i i would i would do it and you know
why because i've met so many nice people
here in uk i've been fully supported by
journalists by my legal team who started
to work pro bono without even payment
did you ever get the compensation it was
reported that you were to get a much
smaller amount than when you had gone in
for but did the russian state ever pay
you
no i i'll tell you some very uh if i can
call this funny story because our house
was contaminated
and after
it was released polonium 2010 killed my
husband we should get out from our house
in just 30 minutes
and when in two months they said all
police investigation completes it
we can go back to the home
but it's contaminated and need to be
cleaned
and priced for 300 000 pounds
to clean your house yes from poison from
polonium from radioactivity
of course we couldn't pay
and i remember in that time again i
mentioned him
tycoon boris barizovsky who was a direct
critics of vladimir putin who was in
exile here he said it's putin should
come to london and clean this house
himself
this was like that but nobody paid and
we were waiting for two years and a half
until it became
clean completely natural
so you can live in your home
no
and you've still never received any
compensation this was compensation from
british government in
basic level you know even less if you
have some damage in mcdonald's
but not from russia just to go back to
your house and i don't think again
people necessarily think about that they
see that image of your husband um which
i believe did you take the photo
no i didn't do it myself but this was uh
offered to take a picture of sasha i was
disagreeing because i didn't want people
to see him like that because i didn't
think he will die
i wanted to keep his image as normal
that's how he looks yes but but there
was and is this image now people are
very familiar with
uh and that was important to him for
people to see yes sasha you know i just
realized many things what sasha tried to
do and people could not understand in
some moment they just realized much
later yeah and and the reason going back
to that is
people may not have realized that it
took it took several weeks for him and
to deteriorate and and eventually
which i'm so sorry about i must say that
um but your house being contaminated
like that i mean what what were those
weeks like what do you remember of them
what i said sasha was poisoned first of
november but it was not recognized till
he started to show definitely
as an illness of a
chemical or radioactive
but doctors still not able to find a
reason why he became so ill and we all
this time is staying in the house
because we didn't know this is
radioactivity or it might be dangerous
to live in the house and only 23rd of
november when sasha died and first time
i heard about radioactive polonium
been asking to get out from home
but seeing sasha during these weeks
changing so much it was a torture
not just for me but i just felt how he
felt because he couldn't eat he couldn't
drink
immediately since first of november
but
he was in pain constantly really but
even if of this he knew
he should give statement to police
she should give his evidences where he
went when uh
when and who he met and he did it for
last
hours of his life i'm sorry to make you
think back to that time but i think it's
important for people to hear how it was
quite normal and then the symptoms
started to show and and what actually
happened to him and how difficult that
was and you have been and your son i
presume were exposed to
the potential effects of the
radioactivity is that right yes we had
testing after sasha died and uh
thankfully anatoly our son didn't have
any
polonium in his body i had slightly
higher than normal
but it was not very bad compared to
sasha and i was saying you're not going
to die
at least no i ask is
good at least i'm not going dying now
but i said it might affect your life in
the future
you might have high risk to develop
cancer
it's all what a message i received how
do you process that that you you have to
live with the threat of potential cancer
because your husband was poisoned
you know um maybe i'm trying to
think less about myself
because everything would happen then i
was thinking more about our son
and i just
thought oh my god it would be so unfair
if
no parents would be with my son now
because it was second huge challenge in
his life how old was your son when it
happened he was 12.
there's a certain age when everything is
difficult
just six years before he was moved from
one country to another one without his
asking because he was just a child and
this was not easiest
trip
from russia to nowhere and finally
landed in uk and when life looked so
easy and good
and go to school and again it's changed
so dramatically of course i was much
very much worried about him and this
helps me
to think like to think less about myself
how is he today is he able to live a
relatively normal life
you know it's interesting when we uh um
received political asylum here yes
and we had a protection name like
english name
and sashi explained it would be easy to
ask to travel not to have a lot of
attention
and
when anatolia was 15
and he said mommy could i change my
english name to my real name
anatoly litvinianca when i will have my
adult passport i say yes of course you
can do it but something
happened and he didn't change
but now he asked me again
i'm definitely going to change really my
passport for my real name anatoly
lithium i can see it's quite emotional
talking about that though about your
identity and your son and
and how he feels about that yes but i'm
very proud of him because his life
wasn't easy when you are teenager you
want to live your life meet friends but
when you see every time picture of your
father or your mother or himself and
in the newspaper it was very difficult
and he avoids his publicity first time
he agreed to talk to media after
malaysian aeroplane was shut down
he was emotional
so breaking he told me i don't
understand these people
because they will not have justice
russian did it and they just lost their
relatives but they will not be able to
find justice
what was his point
do you want to be able to go back to
russia
theoretically yes
but every time when i was thinking i'm
ready to go to russia something happened
it was like a message not now
because uh a long time i couldn't even
think about my travel to rush after
my husband was killed
then when i was almost ready we started
this whole process about
inquest public inquiry and
i was not stopped and of course i was
not recommended but i knew i do
understand i could stop in russia
and not being arrested not nothing but i
would be just stopped and not be able to
travel back uh to uk because i'm still
the russian citizens
and my british citizens doesn't work
in russia it's not recognized not
recognized not recognized in this case i
knew i need to be there to provide
everything what i can do for for this uh
my kind of justice for sasha
next
it was poisoning of scrippali and
everything what happened to me
to my husband alexandre lithuanian was
again all in publicly talking about and
this was message from russia we still
have investigate this case too
and they had different opinion and
they're saying behind of this crime this
is
berisovsky
mi6
and cia
this was all strong message to me if i'm
going to russia i'm definitely would be
uh
asked to give my statement or to
cooperate or
anything could happen
do you still have close family there i
have not my
direct my my parents unfortunately died
and you know and sometimes i think
they're just so likely not to think all
of what happened now between ukraine
between russia
i still have my cousins and you know i'm
a little bit worried to talk to them
because of safety
because of what their opinions oh
really yes
even within your own family that can be
that sort of even this and i heard
already about how many families or very
close friends but many years
now stop to be together because of this
and this is another point what i try to
rise every time what putin did to these
people
and they're completely brainwashed
they have no any other opinions they're
afraid to say truth not all of them
because we see this all protest in
moscow and saint peter's book and of
course we need to support these people
because this is hope for new russia and
they might help to change russia one day
thank you very much for talking to me
thank you thank you so much for being
with us until we meet again take care
and goodbye
[Music]
you